You cannot trust the things of this
world that always let you down.
You cannot trust in yourself.
Because you're not perfect and
you will always make mistakes.
And you cannot trust in other people
because they always let you down.
But if your confidence is in God,
you will always have peace and joy.
Hey guys,
Have you ever seen mature Christian men, and man,
it just looks like nothing can get this guy down.
How do you become like that?
How how does he do it?
They just act in strength - they
always walk - talk and act - in boldness.
And with a lot of confidence.
So how do they do it?
And where does this confidence come from?
Well, it is not self-confidence.
It is God confidence.
And today, I want to talk to you about this
very important distinction that I believe every
Christian man should know - the difference
between self-confidence and God confidence.
In your life, it can be natural, normal for you
to rely on your own human abilities and strengths.
But that is also where your power will end.
And that's pretty sad.
But as reborn Christians, we are
called to rely on God's strength.
His power.
And not our own.
We are called to place our confidence
in God and not in ourselves.
Because there is where we will get
more power to be able to overcome
things that we will never be able to
overcome with just our own human power.
Our abilities come from Him in the first place.
But He can do a lot more than our abilities.
He gives us - equips us - with what
we need to accomplish His will - so
we don't just need to rely on ourselves.
If you understand it and if you obey it,
your whole life will change because you understand
that there is nothing in this temporary world that
can overcome you.
Why?
Because the God of the universe - I mean He
spoke the whole universe into existence. Man...
He is not limited by anything.
Not by time, space, matter, or anything at all.
God is in your corner and He will fight with you.
Not only with you, but for you.
[1 John 4:4]
Self-confidence is not totally wrong.
If you understand it in the correct way.
Understanding who you are - who God made you to
be - being content with your identity in Christ.
Then that is okay to understand
it, but still as human beings,
our own strength is limited.
Your human abilities are limited.
And your confidence in yourself can fall
especially when faced with challenges that
are beyond your control, which
usually happens in this world.
But as reborn Christians, we are not alone.
So why do you keep on living and
fighting as if you are on your own?
As a reborn Christian in your body,
which is the temple of God, you
have received the Spirit of God.
[Romans 8:9]
If in fact the spirit of God dwells
in you, anyone who does not have
the Spirit of Christ does not belong to Him.
So when you stop looking at yourself all the
time, trying to have self-confidence,
placing your trust, your confidence
relying on yourself, and you take that out and you
place it in Christ, it changes everything for you.
Because now you tap into His limitless power.
Love.
Peace.
All the spiritual
blessings we have already received in Christ.
We only need to access it and then doing it the
right way through the power of the Holy Spirit,
the Holy Spirit will now help you and guide you,
your emotions, your intellect, your
own will to act within the will of God.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
The will of God will flow through you
towards the outside world.
God's blessing will be upon you
if you act within the will of God, meaning if you
walk within the Spirit, you have nothing to fear.
Nothing at all.
The evil in this world, everything
in this world, temporary (that's temporary).
God has already overcome this world and you
have overcome it through Christ that is in you.
So when you act within the power of God through
His Spirit, everything will
work out the way it should.
And He will help you in your
weakness, even when you pray to God.
When there are times when you're not sure
exactly what to pray, He will help you.
[Romans 8:26]
We walk boldly in faith with power trusting
God in everything, every aspect of our lives.
So if you pray, God, what is my purpose?
What do you want me to do with my life?
And if He talks to you through the Rhema word
and He says that you have to study theology to
become a preacher, then you do it, trusting Him
knowing that He will give you what you need to
study Theology, and also after that you can pray
and say alright God, now I've studied Theology,
I'm ready to become a preacher.
Where do you want me to go?
To what church?
How do you want me to do this?
He talks to you and then you act
according to what He says you need to do.
If He says you need to go and marry Mary.
Then you do it if He says do this.
You do it if He says do that.
You do it.
You walk according to His will.
You trust that He will help you,
will be there guiding you, but He will also give
you - equip you - with what you need
to accomplish His will for your life.
[John 14:21]
Jesus also said that man will not live by bread
alone but by every word of God, right? But that
word is not the Logos word, that is the Rhema.
That is what God communicates to you.
You need to understand this - so the Logos -
the Word is - is the Word that God has already
revealed to us.
The Bible.
But then He also speaks to us through
the Rhema, through the Holy Spirit.
So in the Bible when you read it,
it doesn't say go and marry Mary
or do this or do that and call you by name.
But that is what He does through the Rhema word.
That's how He guides you in your
temporary life that you are living in now.
Specifically telling you to do specific things.
And then you walk in that Rhema word.
So you see, God will not just
help you with the Logos word,
but also the Rhema word through the Holy
Spirit that is in you, guiding you every
step of the way in your life, every day, if
you trust Him, and if you let Him lead you.
Now, take this verse, write
it on your heart, and live it.
[Philippians 4:13] Amplified version.
Wow, man, this is amazing.
You know, there are so many
self-improvement coaches in this world.
And it works a little bit.
But it doesn't really bring a lasting change.
Why not?
Because everyone realizes at some point
in their lives that they are only human
and that they cannot do everything by themselves
on their own, that they cannot control everything.
They get unexpectedly ill - they lose their
job - someone close to them dies - they
do not win the sports match they worked so
hard for - war breaks out in their country.
Covid hits and the list goes on.
In moments like these, lying to yourself
and telling yourself, man, I have confidence
and everything will work out the way it should.
It's kind of like hoping in nothing.
Because you have no power to change reality.
The reality that is outside of you.
There are things in this
world that you cannot control.
I have seen this so many times - men who try
to act and think and try to force themselves
to actually believe themselves - their own
lies - that they are more than they are
and that by just thinking positively,
it will somehow change the reality.
And then when reality hits them in the
face, they are shocked and surprised
and their whole world just crumbles.
You see that especially with young men
who have insecurities and they think that the
answer is trying to tell themselves that they are
alpha males and they try to puff themselves up.
Like with men in a boxing match.
They try to tell themselves I will not lose, I'm
the best, I'm the strongest, I'm great. I - I - I.
And then that eye gets knocked out.
If not in that match, in a later match.
And also in life.
We are all mortal.
For some reason, a lot of us young guys - when
I used to be young - I used to think like that.
But over the years, I saw men die.
Strong men die right before my eyes.
And the way they died changed
my perspective of life.
They used to feel powerful -
ruling their own small world -
only to come to this inevitable moment.
To come to the end of their lives before
they die, realizing they are weak.
Just a human whose time has come.
And they are only dust.
You know, this realization changed one of
these men that I knew completely before he died.
He used to be - I mean he was bigger than me - he
used to be very arrogant and
man, just living for this world.
And puffed up and always when he walked into a
room, you know, he would take control of the room
and trying to kind of force his way through life.
And, oh man, he changed.
I have never seen someone change
that drastically like this man.
When he came to realize the
truth of the world and himself.
No one could tell this guy anything at all.
He was always right.
Me, I'm the man.
And now he comes
to the end of his life, weak, powerless.
He couldn't even drive himself or even go
to the toilet by himself.
I had to help him.
[Psalm 8:4]
Having God's confidence changes everything.
It makes you realize who you truly are,
your identity in Him.
You start to see the world differently.
You get different perspectives, helping
you to overcome challenges much faster.
Oh man.
The person I used to be.
If I know - man - if I knew what I know now.
I would have been so much different.
Made so many better decisions.
The more you grow in God, the more
He changes you to become stronger.
In a sense you - you get weaker in your own
fleshly sinful nature - you get stronger
through the Spirit in Him and you grow in that
confidence, and you see how He is changing you.
He's the potter, you are the clay.
You're becoming stronger, meaning your confidence
viewed in the right way grows far beyond normal
humans who are spiritually dead because their
confidence is in temporary material things.
While you are anchored in God Himself.
You finally start to understand your purpose.
You understand your true identity in Him.
God says:
[Jeremiah 17:5-8]
Do you get it?
This world can do what it wants to you,
but if your confidence is in God,
you will always have peace and joy.
It's like the tree.
You know, the rain can come.
The storms can come.
The sun can beat in the day, but
the roots are in the living water.
Your confidence, your roots are in the
living water which is the Holy Spirit.
God's Spirit that is within you.
Tapping into that unlimited power,
walking within the will of God,
no one and nothing can do anything to you.
Because you are in Christ, and He guards you.
[Proverbs 28:26]
You cannot trust the things of this
world that always let you down.
You cannot trust in yourself because you're
not perfect and you will always make mistakes.
And you cannot trust in other people
because they always let you down.
You can only trust in God.
[Psalm 20:7]
[Proverbs 3:5]
[Psalm 118:8]
You see, placing your trust in God, relying
on Him instead of just relying on your own
human abilities, man, it changes everything.
Because then you don't even care
about other people's opinions.
You only care about what God thinks of you and if
you're walking within His will because if you do,
everything will work out the way it should.
Not only will it help you to fight your battles,
but He will also give you peace,
while you fight the battles.
And those battles will come.
That is why He has given you the
armor of God that you need to put on every day.
And if you do, you will always have peace and joy.
[Isaiah 26:3]
Now, start to live in God confidence
and not in self-confidence.
Draw your strength from the
truth and promises of His Word.
And live it.
To live and
overcome life's challenges with faith joy
and unshakable trust in His divine plan.
Now, if you want to grow stronger in God,
then please watch one of these videos here.
If you haven't subscribed, do so now so
you won't miss any of our future videos.
And I'll see you there.
And always remember,
life is short, so don't waste yours.
Cheers guys.